hello I'm Johnny Knoxville welcome to
Jackie we're on the Paramount back lot
filming the opening sequence of Jackass
forever
we brought in a number of new cast
members I want to say my name all right
this is Zach I'm Jasper and this is body
sorry for your mother this is my first
movie
it was really great to be invited into
the crew and everything what'd you think
Lynn you got the call to come in and sit
down with us first thought was hoping I
don't die then I was like hey at least
I'll die on camera
how you doing over there Rachel we man's
going to space
they made me laugh so hard and I'm
literally seeing childhood Heroes of
mine like come to life
Grandpa are you okay my mind is blown
I'm Eric I'm from South London I love
skating and I love getting a bit hurt
[Applause]
I'm poopies Big Time movie star
my friend chip goes hey I want to
introduce you to a couple of my friends
I want you to come test out for Jackass
[Applause]
and I was like no way like speechless at
that moment it's a Texas rat snake yeah
venomous
but you love snakes no I don't you don't
love snakes no
I was pretty nervous getting brought
into this movie honestly because I'm
doing like crazy stuff with all these
people that I've looked up to my entire
life
those guys are getting old we paid our
dues so we're handing the torch to you
love this dude the new people that we're
working with are great and we've been
destroying them throughout this film
[Music]
like you had to earn it with the guys
for sure
I'm so nervous but yeah I was a dream
come true that's the best part it's like
yeah I'm afraid of doing this
[Music]
but it's gonna look awesome
[Music]
laughs
[Music]